oh
[Musique]
les enfants le chien
les bagagistes
mois d'août
[Musique]
cet encadrement trois mois
trois ans déménage dh et 12 lettieri
ces petites génisses et puis deux vaches
autres de notre goût à tuer
[Musique]
ben 10
trail entrée libre
le port rive et la badr façon adroite
[Musique]
alé lô gens tu viens
on va montrer le parc pour les vaches
du coup la limite de la parcelle c ou
alors c'est ça la celle là en fait il ya
un chemin là qui remonte là comme ça la
veille à 1 10 et 1
8 ouais je crois au mythe ou neuf
quartiers pleine nuit quand les vaches
et m lle mur
bon bout
[Rires]
après
la liberté où les murs bougent manquera
pourtant pas très bien on va montrer la
mer
est vachement voir quoi
mado parce qu'elle va voir les vaches tu
vois quoi toi non pas la mer
la nuit elle doit être ébloui par le
crioc il
ya toujours bien
à gauche
un tome assez les brebis acharné salon
bleu ciel
[Musique]
et là on est à
berne et le boulou et 101
ryan mais qui pêche le mont sion va
faire la pêche aux poissons non plus
bon quand même
tu vois ça fait trois fois que je viens
et c'est toujours la même la même boule
là j'ai passé les forte énergie mais du
coup ça me ressource moi je me sens
vraiment bien
c'est beaucoup
trop beau
puis bon on voit que les enfants ils
sont bien
crapahute barthou et
[Musique]
pas besoin de portable
en fait je pense que si on s'est vus ici
c'est pour
[Musique]
refaire on a le noyau familial mais pour
essayer de plus se recentrer en fait sur
nous on a tellement mis en avait
tellement de travail on va travailler
ici un mais on a eu tellement de boulot
dans la drôme que
bacon super d1 mais
j'ai l'impression qu'ici ça va encore
plus nous resserrer que ce que ce qu on
que ce que l'on est et je pense à
important quoi donc c'est cool
il faut juste que les garçons apprennent
à gérer les bars et maintenant
bon ben je crois qu'on les a perdus
et on va essayer de monter là bas je le
sens mal de saint malo situés à c'est
que pour les appeler ça fait loin qui va
vite
tu as 25 hectares et ses plans pour
faire du fourrage de par exemple pour un
nouveau maître de ballet symphonie je
demande à la mairie alors si on pourrait
les voir là q que vous avez la mairie
qui peut quoi parce qu'il ne faut pas
faut pas d'abord et le
cd contient
[Rires]
le nom mais moi je suis obligée non mais
faut pas brusquer
les jambes et sans avant ils savaient
des sillons toute façon si tu casses les
sillons
les
caisses la tradition nous et sans et du
coup ça il faut pas faire
mais il ya 35 hectares que vous pouvez
cultiver
là si tu penses que là on sera pas
emmerdé implanté du piquet bois et tue
les gens n'iront
[Musique]
jamais je dis bien
tout le baril à bientôt merci pour
m'indiquer les plans
d'eau
à lévis
[Musique]
il ya une demande qui est de plus en
plus forte pour avoir des produits qui
sont locaux et qu'ils sont sains et ici
où on a de quoi faire donc il faut aussi
en profiter en sang soo voilà si on
respecte l'environnement bain à côte et
tout ira je pense qu'on peut être aussi
assez accueillante et ouverte justement
nouvelles personnes
donc on aura chacun son exploitation
chacun sa production aussi mais on aura
quelques pièces et quelques partis en
commun ou que ça va être un peu un
travail d'équipé aussi je pense entre
nous trois
signes qui me tient quand même beaucoup
pas car vu que ma famille d'ici et j'ai
passé mon enfance donc c'est quand même
beaucoup de souvenirs et beaucoup de
présents aussi puisque j'y vis depuis
cinq ans à l'année et puis travailler
les moutons sera est quand même dans
l'histoire de l'île et la continuité
aussi de ce qu'on avait avant donc c'est
important aussi de lier cette cette
passion et cet endroit quoi ont une
seule chose quoi
bon et bien dormi
amine met à l'abri
[Musique]
ici c'est une équipe
démarré comme ça on n'a pas de soucis
[Musique]
allez c'est parti la regarde
banyuls
le tractopelle et ce matin maintenant
[Musique]
fallait qu'on le débarque la bonne
marche
[Musique]
on va essayer de faire les parcs pour
les clôtures des vaches
entre les matchs puissent arriver aux
moineaux
on va planter quelques piques et
yannick ont planté le premier a dit m
tchèque
on
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pour canaliser les vaches
pour avoir un truc solide et après à la
journée on peut faire des petits parcs
mobiles avec des petits piquets pour par
départ de jours en fait
ça va faire chouette
on était vraiment bien dans la drôme a
mais on a l'impression que c'est ce
qu'on attendait
pour une fois les gamins était couchée
tôt et puis on s'est installé devant la
télé et puis on va regarder thalassa
c'est sur l'île d'ouessant et voilà
c'était chouette hein les phares
et puis trois jours après thomas en
gardant la météo pour partir fauché il
voit deux sous la mairie d'ouessant
l'un son appel d'offres cherche éleveurs
laitiers du coup ils m'envoient sa part
message et puis je dis mais pourquoi tu
m'envoies ça avant la bretagne ça va
toujours fait rêver vous pourrez
travailler
sur une île que tous les deux avoir nos
bêtes
et puis puis voilà quoi changer de vie
au sucre et donc il a appelé la mairie
et puis bon il a expliqué que notre
profil ça se dit ça fait 12 ans qu'on
est éleveur dans la drôme vente directe
trois enfants donc les deux plus petits
étaient à fond le plus grand
moyen
normal 1 12 ans le collège les amis la
famille et puis bon on a répondu à
l'appel d'offres mais sans trop y croire
et
ben voilà on était tellement fond je
crois
compris il y en a beaucoup qui nous
prennent pour des fautes qu'ils disent
mais vous allez être propriétaire de
rien
et alors et en fait ça dans mon angle
écoles n'y en a pas beaucoup qui
sont pas attachés à la terre
en soi quoi c'est la terre de beaucoup
de propriétaires ici c'est pas la mienne
moi je m'en fous tant que ça peut faire
nous nourrir mes animaux qu'on nous la
loulou camp nou là prête j'ai pas besoin
d'être propriétaires terriens pour me
sentir bien dans ma tête quoi
oh
et
[Musique]
nous
m
[Musique]
là on atteint des proies de 4,5 tonnes
avec des mouvements possibles des
animaux à l'intérieur donc faut y aller
tout doucement il faut deux heures deux
heures de merde ici
pour moi c'est la première fois en dix
ans et qu'on emmène autant d'animaux en
même temps vers les îles dans le sens
d'une installation c'est la première
fois c'est un renouveau
[Musique]
e
en fait les ont entraîné un tsunami
durée mais il ya une semaine et c'était
beaucoup plus compliqué au niveau de la
mer donc bon en même temps ça nous a
permis de mettre en place ici donc là
c'est bon
[Musique]
c'est pour dire c'est que peut penser
oui kp y aura la mise en place avec la
traite
les fromages
en
[Musique]
oui et bien vous gagnez
la le projet en fait donc au final avoir
un laboratoire
du coup ça c'est le
vous seriez avec la mairie lacchini ce
livre on construit un bâtiment vert
attaque affaire du lait février mars
attacks à transformer direct
elle à l'écoulement des marchandises
savez
on espère vendre ici et avec du coup une
partie en fromage donc tout ce qui est
produits frais et ça se voit que ça se
paye couple est rapidement parce que ça
ne regarde pas donnera quoi en volume
et bas une vache comme ça en début de
lactation c'est une vingtaine de lits
alors c'est une belle attraction parce
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
se sont arrêtés pour voir les vaches
puis pour disputer donc ça c'est
vachement agréable mais n'ont pour
l'instant un bel accueil beaucoup de
gens ne sont impatients de manger du
beurre et du fromage
donc c'est cool non pour l'instant un
bel accueil bras
et après la prochaine grande étape
passée arrivés de tout le monde ici quoi
mais voilà 31,2 ce sera tous fini on
croise consacrer à 100%
m
on va
installer une pompe solaire donc on
le goûte rio qui va descendre dans le
puits jusqu'à la pompe
ouais vous pour l'instant
moi
ça va vouloir refaire des boucles
cet été dans les faits les parfums dans
un puits donc c'est tant mieux parce que
mon transporter de l'eau pas très
marrant donc 6 1 puis c'est mieux
pourquoi c'est une pompe solaire
est censé fonctionner même pas que de la
luminosité parce que ça a pris les
panneaux qui sont
surdimensionnés par rapport à la pompe
donc
uniquement le
la lumière devrait le faire fonctionner
donc c'est un test
on va voir
la nuque on a sept mètres et il ya deux
mètres d'eau mais bon en fait
n'a pas tellement plus encore
à temps parce que tant câble électrique
talent et pas du creuzil cette eau douce
est livré avec des noeuds et je ne sais
pas tu as qu'il a fait après ben ali de
moi je supporte pas mais marie-hélène
bien mais si l'aide complémentaire donc
je laisse les choses que j'aime pas et
bon
alors ça
tu laisses la palette pour aller
chercher l'argent
non la vraie base de règles nous nous on
a du mal ou comme moi en tout cas j'ai
du mal à prendre les marques parce que
ce n'est pas le même mari peu qu'on
avait dans la drôme s'était déjà tout en
place que ici
on a les vaches à s'occuper en même
temps on à l'organisation à mettre en
route et puis ça va être je pense une
grosse année d'apprentissage où on va se
dire bah ce qu'on avait prévu
ce sera pas comme ça on va faire
autrement
par exemple là on pensait que on aurait
assez d'herbe du côté où on avait fait
les parcs au début puis finalement on
est un peu limite donc on est venu sur
une autre zone
cap à l'eau là y'a pas la propre sol air
qui n'a jusqu'ici donc en transportent
de l'eau sont bien grave tu t'enfonces
le tractopelle qui veut jamais démarré
il ya tellement de choses à faire ici
les journées passent à une vitesse pour
la reine temps d'avancé que la fin de la
journée fait quoi
donc c'est compliqué de tout tout gérer
les grands bonne nuit
c'est mon lors du coup on n'est pas mort
e
[Musique]
à
le
[Musique]
où
e
allons à l'eau et valeo vient chercher
les who what avoir suivi à 10 ou 20
tours est arrivé le que le 28 décembre
prise de possession de la maison pour
les enfants de voir leurs chambres
euh ouais c'est mes poules
elles ont pris la mesure et son muscat
et 6 et 10 ans un peu peur ouais c'est
moi qui m'ont accueille tous les jours
elle est cool
moi j'aime bien jouer sans skis bien ya
quasi pas beaucoup de voitures d'antan
moi je vois que passer avant tu croyais
plus qu'il y avait trop de voitures ici
c'est mieux c'est tentant mae tu te sens
plus paisible
nom de l'ua joue déjà
[Musique]
on était vachement content des ménages
est bas on était bien à la thrombine
mais ici au mans ça change un petit peu
je sais bien que s'aventurer un peu mais
notre et sans ma tête
[Musique]
il faut que les quatre veaux qui sont
nés
balade autour du cou mais la première
balle est née fin janvier du coup la
vraie vie
yao
etc
m
on la pensait open bars
puis elle doit se voir ces capelines
plus matin et soir parce qu'elle nous
vie de nectarines qu on
n a que deux et demi à traire quoi
bon avec effroi elles produisent moins
aussi et on n'a pas le droit de vendre
non plus parce qu'il faut qu'il soit
refroidi à 2 degrés pour le vendre donc
là pour l'instant on fait du troc
selon matin et soir et puis tu te re
découvre des muscles
des petites chutes
on vous avait annoncé un gel jamais
après qu'il pleuve qu'il vente si tu es
bête elles sont à l'abri qu'elle souffre
pas bon voilà c'est le temps quoi
ou la
has madrid
[Musique]
les frères
m
effroi manning
[Musique]
elle dit ça ils sont sympas et gentiment
tôt si beaucoup minuit
un mois d'arrêt ça nous a
souri je pense déjà
tu vois pour les vaches j'en achèterais
bien une ou deux quand même nom le pays
comme nous que les dépenses et les
années prochaines
on a déjà sorti 90000 euros ah ouais
mais bon tu te rends compte quand même
que la mise en place c'est
[Musique]
énorme installez
droite travaillait à dépenser déjà cent
mille euros et encore on est dans des
structures autour on construit pas de
bâtiment
on n'achète pas de terrain
non mais si on ne peut pas être installé
en haut
au total je serai à 110000 euros
d'investissement et puis là j'ai déjà
dépensé 60 mille euros donc il faut que
l'argent rentre d'un an pour que faut
qu'on puisse rembourser un peu tout ça
voilà tous les brebis sont arrivés puis
maintenant je m'installe du coup
tranquillement
le 1er mars normalement je suis installé
si tout va bien et puis les agneaux
comment est-ce qu'on arrivait à partir
du 10 qu'après la production et puis
après c'est parti quoi
[Applaudissements]
production locale ouais c'est le lait
des vaches de lörrach ce matin les eu
beau se répéter note parce que commence
à prendre les notes mais c'est les oeufs
des poules de charlène
et puis la farine c'est la fine la drôme
j'ai mangé les premières qui sont jolies
bon alors c'est quoi les noirs ce soir
malouda nouveau
mais malheureusement à droite une geek
alors du coup tu comprends pas la faire
ça une fois
l affaire qui démarre
à tous
oui on a commencé à imaginer deux
phrases oui c'est plus tard a dit c'est
la
bourgogne donc ça veut dire vous savez
bien d amiens pas
très romantique que j'aime bien regarder
les nuages avec où commencer le nuage
ça a
roulé beaucoup de remonter ce qui est
dit comme ça
c'est un peu trop épais
[Musique]
c'est parti mon kiki
bon là
la rentrée s'est bien passée pour toi
policier ça a été
vous êtes combien dans sa classe l'année
5 mai nord
après l'important c'est le plus grand
toit il est né
il ya maintenant je crois va lancer le
voici le plus petit ce que tu sais temps
on note rien de bon et sa police
tu t'inquiètes pas je l'aimé assez à
ploaré voir la définition pour
l'implantation
a été bien accueillie timmy
ses comptes en jeu une bonne expérience
pour moi
les skis et bottes ici qu'est ce qui te
plaît
après
c'est bien tu fais beaucoup de vélo
puis tu es un petit peu dépendant quoi
tu es toi tu fais un petit peu ce que tu
veux quoi t'as pas trop de tracas c'est
une petite idée
on tu seras plus grand sur quoi tu veux
te
projeter ou te diriges
énormément je pense ouvrir à l'alcool
dans les tracteurs photo
dc une belle-fille qui passent dans la
rue mais
bon je pense qu'on est pas mal
tim sais pas ce que tu en penses au
niveau des longueurs et c'est
assez équilibré
bon bah team je te libère
ainsi de cette première visite
allait passer le bac après midi merci au
revoir
[Musique]
bah en fait au début je jouais pas ce
que c'était alors je voulais pas partir
et dès que celui-ci s'était bien sûr
tout cet été je pense avec marc
bénié
bas j'aime bien tout la mer autour il
fait un peu bizarre c'est que ces plats
sont pas relâchés mois avant
ma famille m'ont beaucoup avec mes
copains parce que avant j'étais comment
dire par exemple pas et va quand
j'allais voir que là je peux pas aller
les voir c'est un peu moins quand on
travaille on va aller voir les copains à
chaque week-end serai avec eux du coup
ça faisait la petite sélection qu'on se
connaissait c'est ça un peu dur
[Musique]
passer d'un collège presque 700 élèves
un collège j'avais quatorze élèves 15
maintenant c'est bien parce que fait je
connais tout le monde c'est marrant ça
mais après voilà
[Musique]
enfin équipé le camion pour faire une
fois majeurs bizarre
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait déjà du lille donc
falloir qu'on transforme sol et quoi
bon c'est aussi là mais ça permettra de
ne pas gaspiller du lait au moins
le bâtiment que la mairie est en train
de construire pour nous à au moins 6 8
mois de retard mon conte sera jamais
prêt pour le mois de mars pour le début
de lactation pour nous et pour charlène
donc chacun chacune des deux fermes a dû
trouver des solutions donc nous n'avons
voilà la solution c'est le camion
[Musique]
aurait préféré démarrer plus tôt dans la
nouvelle fromagerie connaître l'impact
financier c'est qu'on veut pas louper
non plus est en panne de l'école puisque
nous avoir du lait il faut qu'on le
transforme et qu'on puisse le vendre
quoi
on va essayer d'organiser un petit
marché de producteurs avec charlène et
puis vincent le maraîcher quand enfin
plus ce sera ici mais quand comment on
n'est pas encore au point parce que
j'attends qu'on n'est pas en route en
fait on n'arrive pas à s'imaginer ce qui
peut se passer quoi
[Musique]
7 si
les vaches vont bien on a eu nos 14
euros sur douze villages
super bien passé on a eu deux paires de
jumeaux en plus on a eu que trois mâles
ont semaine donc le renouvellement est
assurée
du coup en un mois et demi a pu monter
la machine à traire qui est arrivée dans
les temps
super truc
comme à ses cadres bien à traire moi je
serais pas du coup le matin en fait on a
trouvé notre équilibre thomas y traînent
matin moi je devais traire le soir en
fait vu que la vente s'est mise en place
le soir ben thomas ils préfèrent traire
que vers l'avant toit et moi j'adore
faire ça donc voilà
les résultats
m
j'ai le droit quand
[Rires]
merci
vas-y
maeder
radar
il y a
la vente de yahoo se marchent bien ça
commence à vraiment se développer parce
que je fais un york nature et citron et
du coup le citron plaît bien aussi
donc ça c'est cool parce que c'est sur
les yaourts qu'on gagne sa vie quoi donc
arriver à gagner sa vie quand même parce
qu'on a fait beaucoup de dépenses et
pour faire des rencontres et des
renforts mais
c'est vraiment super important qu'il ya
une activité agricole qui ce qu'ils
revivent sur l'île
avant la deuxième guerre mondiale lille
était autosuffisante en tout toutes les
parcelles étaient cultivées
il y avait des vaches des cochons
on a du mal à imaginer ça aujourd'hui
quand on voit le l'enfrichement en
général et les
c'est le seul problème c'est le seul
problème c'est hyper brillant
m quinze panneaux solaires
elle mettrait re solaire
allez les gars allait bien aller bien
aller vite
by one
ya trop bonnes minutes un jour là à tous
au total on doit être à
208 jours avec les boucles ouais même un
peu plus parce qu'on se fait avec trois
athlètes ont rempli la cub qui fait
presque 250 litres
c'est un obligé de transformer tous les
jours et demi
[Musique]
donc la g 210 litres de lait du coup je
récupère des litres de crème
qui normalement doit faire sans club et
ça c'est une étape qui est trop belle
moche quoi la séparation du lait de la
crème je trouve ça trop beau quand en
plus la crainte de jersey elle sort
vraiment très très jeune quoi en
converse s'en trouve pas de la crème
aussi jeune homme quand on aura ce futur
laiterie on pourra avoir une capacité
plus importante au niveau de la cuve au
pouvoir stocker du lait pour transformer
votre les jours quoi alors après on
s'aperçoit que la les vaches elles
tourneur quand même bien parce qu'on a
plus de 20 litres de lait par jour et
par vache donc normalement peut-être
avec 15 ou 20 vaches andré largement de
quoi vivre et ça m'étonnerait qu'on est
de 1000 euros de salaire chacun un terme
mais si déjà on arrive à sortir mille
cinq cent mille 500 c'est bien on c'est
sûr que ramé au taux horaire des
binettes samedi
mais bon on fait pas ce métier là pour
gagner de l'argent
ça c'est la crème que j'ai fait il ya
deux jours
et qu'on va faire en beurre
maintenant que c'est bon
pas trop mal d'amour
fait le beurre sa demande lâchement de
temps quoi chaque fois
d'après selon à mouler aussi je n'ai pas
la bonne méthode encore pour mouler j'ai
pas de moule il est bon goût mais
mais voilà quoi
apparemment oui quand même ça fait plus
jolie
c'est plus qu'un petit à naltchik
[Applaudissements]
où ce lundi
et
bien du coup vu ce qu'ont fait le marché
maintenant tous les samedis matins on a
mis en place dans la semaine dernière
pour essayer de vendre des gens qu'on ne
voit pas forcément qu'ils peuvent pas
forcément se déplacer en fait là où ont
trait à chaque fois donc voilà je
prépare les copains comme info 40g 82
les digues en tout chocolat café mélangé
et à 30 yards s'y trompe
alors
est ce trop c'est aussi 30 regarde malo
dans la glacière bleus il ya un pot il
ya marqué chantal
avec la nature oui
nature en plus ouais et
alors ça fait 2 et 4 1 à 4
80 au lieu de 4 8 20
on est à notre troisième remises
d'espèces
mais on travaille qu'avec les gens doués
sont pas mais vraiment que les gens
doués sens parce que de quelques vides
il ya pas du tout touriste et du coup on
n'arrive déjà pas à suivre un cri gens
que douze ans
après là où on s'est loupés dans nos
prévisionnel c'est que on pensait pas
que les gens achèteraient autant les web
et les gens ils cuisinent quoi font du
riz au lait j'ai jamais entendu le mot
riz au lait autant de fois qu on met
nous dans la drôme jamais et entendez
parler de riz au lait c'est peut-être pu
j'ai trois litres de lait alors 3-0 et
la semaine prochaine verra du beau temps
avait réservé qua non j'ai pas j'ai pas
mal on oublie les veut prendre pitch ah
ben oui mais non
oui bon écoute non j'ai pas grave on en
est un je te note parce que sinon on
n'aura jamais
avec lui les deux sens
est ce que tu veux à bout
depuis que marie et thomas sont arrivés
sur ouessant il ya beaucoup de gens qui
se remémore plein de choses l'ancien
temps
il y avait beaucoup de bas chez moi je
revois ma grand-mère traire la vache
avait 6 7 ans et je le monte toujours me
coucher après avoir vu bon verre de lait
tiède on va maintenant espérer souhaité
et faire tout ce qu'il faut pour garder
thomas et marie avec nous très longtemps
par contre tout mettra du beurre de côté
je pars à rouen le 5 mai j'arrive et je
me mets alors une livre
mais il ya tellement de monde ici c'est
incroyable et on en demande en
augmentant d'une bien ici prend deux
trublions en tout cas vous êtes super
bien intégré à ouessant est super sympa
et ça marche
c'est l'anti
gao et le 28 pour le bleu
c'est tout un hommage à la
ville et la prochaine mais bon
ça a bien marché les gens sont bien
revenus et tous
ses biens c'est cool
ouais les gens sont sont sensibles quand
même au goût quoi et tu prouves
en fait ce qui est bien c'est que je
retrouve ce que les gens ont apprécié
dans la drôme pour les yaourts consul
principalement parce que le fromage
basset nouveau donc c'est vrai que je
veux pas les décevoir en textures et en
goût et
mais du coup elle les gens reviennent
chaque semaine donc enfin voilà ça fait
que la de la deuxième fois mais
on a vu d'autres gens en plus des gens
qu'on avait pas vu la semaine dernière
donc le bouche à oreille marche
c'est bien ça saigne à l'italie ouais
ouais
bush ans et j'aurais zappé en nous un
nouveau
sous les feux de bois
la merde mais véro il est hélas et
citron
alors moi c'est ma façon moi c'est ma
façon en fait de faire le phare y en a
qui font le phare nature il y en a qui m
que du pruneau y en a qui mettent que
des raisins et nous pour faire plaisir à
tout le monde mais les deux oui moi
j'aime bien les deux
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
replongés dans dans le far breton dans
les plans eux dans le riz au lait avec
du lait comme ça c'est vrai que c'est
tellement bon
il est à fait certain que depuis qu'on a
sonné là on a pas tendance amaigri à
notre
les pruneaux ne bouge pas là parce
qu'autrement sa bouille qui on est maire
prai
donc voilà l'opération est terminée
yapluka à temps pour pouvoir déguster
bien
il arrive à tout cela on va on va passer
aux choses sérieuses
bon alors t'as vu ce qu'on arrive à fait
avec le lait de ses vaches
c'est exceptionnel
la couleur c'est
bien sûr
allez vas-y il peut que servir à ne faut
pas secouer
bon
super bon c'est quoi qui est meilleur
mais raison non j avais pas très envie
mais c'est bien cuit petit crossover
aussi qui fait son beurre savez le vrai
beurre si on voit la différence bieber
on est bien calé
grâce à michel
non mais ça a été notre premier rôle est
oui avait deux ans même que londres et
jean louis jean louis voilà exactement
où on a tout mangé un ado
avait apprécié aussi les flancs the way
elle faisait je crois que les manger
tout seul ah ouais moi j'aime bien les
flancs au début quand on donne et les là
les gens étaient contents alors il nous
nous et des gâteaux wever les gens ont
besoin de ça aussi je pense de
d'aller discuter cinq minutes de chez
moi tu vois des gens oui et puis c'est
95% des ouessantins
m
il est vrai de vrai
[Musique]
m
allez
yahoo
[Musique]
on
les gâteaux et des gâteaux
facteurs
d'abord il ya une boîte
ici le siège
cherche it en mangeant le gâteau
bien comme ça
je pense qu'ici faut vraiment puisque on
essaie de faire c'est de vivre un peu au
rythme du soleil
et je pense mais c'est une plus
reposants
du coucher de soleil c'est chouette mais
lever de soleil tu as carrément des
lumières
impressionnante
de plus les avec le un peu la rosée du
matin là ça te fait le seul qui se
réchauffe la saf et les évaporations un
truc comme ça qu'ils sont
simples
et puis il y eut un moment on a commencé
à faire le marché du coup avec marie et
thomas et et puis oui il ya une belle
émotion depuis la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vus du coup parce que maintenant
je prends soin en tout le lait et puis
et puis tout est vendu quoi donc
françois rouan fromage frais et fromage
blanc pour l'instant
je suis contente parce que du coup il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont intéressés par
par le fromager qui jouent le jeu aussi
d'acheter local et puis les touristes
qui sont aussi que lieu de voir ce qu'on
fait ici quoi ce qu'on fait sur lle
louey
7 et pétales de roses se lie au piment
d'espelette ils marchent bien en brebis
c'est la première fois qu'il ya du
fromage de fabriquer du coup c'est une
nouveauté
prend ça fait du bien aux gens surtout
sur une terre comme ça où
on est quand même assez proche
des traditions et tout ça deux remis à
balai qui sort du pis de la vache et qui
est toujours
ce qu'il ya vraiment du goût de l'école
[Musique]
la province
plusieurs fois ci je vends
pour donner un peu de leur potager
saveurs nature non à l'ail ses doigts
kaffrine malien est incapable
[Musique]
alors yaourt et citron et nature nature
et
pourtant que ça marche voilà
est-ce que les ouessantins vont les
accepter on se pose la question
le
alors c'est un peu plus de goût c'est
moins scruté six mois c'est différent
c'est le bilan en fait de ses 1 an ou
deux on se dit aucun regret parce que
c'est vraiment la vie comme je me
l'imaginais au niveau de ma ferme et
même au niveau des enfants même si cette
année on a vraiment pas pu en profiter
correctement pascual à ses débuts de
l'installation ça mais
c'est une réussite
je prends pour l'instant c'est une
réussite
on est bien
[Musique]
parce que au niveau
la ferme professionnel c'est vraiment ce
qu'on recherchait ce qu'on attendait
d'une ferme quoi c'est que voilà ça
reste d'élevage qu'on maîtrise qu'à peu
près à taille humaine et comment vous
voulez quoi avec les bêtes qu'ils soient
dehors fait notre prix du lait ont fait
notre prix du fromage et on sait que
c'est un métier où faut faire des heures
mais c'est un métier de passion et quand
même parce que vrai qu'on s'éclate quand
même temps
et puis avec l'arrivée de la maison qui
n'était pas du tout prévu c'est le
la petite cerise sur le gâteau quoi
on va vraiment pouvoir poser nos valises
et puis je pensais pas que ça serait
autant important pour les enfants on les
avait bien conditionné comme quoi on
achèterait pas ici parce que ce qui est
vraiment trop cher et le fait qu'on ait
pu trouver cette maison accessible à nos
finances 20 les garçons se sentent bien
ça les rassure ouais ouais pour les
enfants je crois que c'était important
ouais c'était important
prochaine étape prendre plus de temps
pour nous
on avait dit aux diverses bien on se
retranche il est vachement tarrier
maintenant on a des travaux à faire une
maison
mais je joue à ce niveau
galanterie
là il
ouais
[Musique]
à